You let the business owner know.
Say, Mr. Business Owner, I have a, you know,
I got this, when you call it,
when I'm gonna get it in a second,
you're gonna let them know you have a lead.
You're gonna let the business owner,
hey, for these first couple of leads,
I'm actually gonna do a live transfer.
I am going to have the lead on the phone.
So Mr. Business Owner, Mr. Business Owner,
you got my number, save it in your phone
and make sure to save it all caps, answer phone.
This is a hot lead, okay?
I need you to answer this call because it's gonna be money.
We're talking about money, it's a digital goal.
So make sure to answer this call
and I'm gonna be calling you back shortly.
Okay, you hang up the phone.
Now what do you do?
You call the lead back.
Hey, Janet, just wanted to let you know
I've got the business owner.
He's gonna be available.
So I'm actually just gonna do a three-way call
and get you guys patched in together.
He's driving.
Hang on one second.
It's gonna go quiet, boom, patch him in, boom, okay?
That's how you're gonna do it for the first
and you're gonna rinse and repeat, rinse and repeat.
Now, some of you guys go,
oh, do you live transfer every single lead for,
no, okay, I used to.
I used to, I thought it was this great upsell
and I used to say, hey, I'm charging you a premium.
Guys, the logistical nightmare
of live transferring every lead is very, very tough, okay?
You'll never, once you get past a couple handful of clients,
you're never gonna be able to do it all
and you're gonna have to have multiple staff on board
and then it's this whole thing.
So I only do this live transfer
during the initial couple of calls, okay?